hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast multiplex
immunofluorescence profiling of tumor
biopsies using Ultraflex MX is
technology presented by dr. Marie Louise
with heart image analysis specialist for
Lika bio systems
aperio ecology and dr. Helen Schneider
director of preclinical development and
strategic partnerships at cell IDs I am
Kaylee vaca blabbers and I will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by lab roots and sponsored by Leica
Biosystems for more information on our
sponsors please visit leica Biosystems
calm now let's get started before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the asset question and click on the
send button will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide window if you have trouble hearing
or seeing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the answer
reflection box located on the far left
of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
we have two presenters for you today
taking first
dr. Helen Schneider dr. Schneider
received her PhD in immunology from the
University of Cambridge UK and trained
as a postdoctoral fellow at Scripps
Research Institute Mahina California dr.
Snyder has over 30 years experience in
immunology research reagent developments
preclinical development of file
therapeutics and business development of
mamuno assay and immuno diagnostic
product following dr. Schneider is dr.
Marie Louise report dr. report has
thirteen years of experience in
biomedical research being trained as a
molecular biologist extending into cell
biology cytogenetics developmental
biology and biochemistry during the
course of her research career
for complete biographies on our speakers
please click on the seeker biographies
tab above the side window dr. Schneider
you may begin our presentation
thank you for joining us today for this
joints a lady acts like a presentation
on multiplex immunofluorescence
profiling tumor biopsies using multiplex
MX AF technology you see this is the
final piece of the puzzle and analyzing
tumor biopsies such information has been
gained from genomic analysis as well as
multi parametric analysis analysis of
dispersed tumor samples by flow
cytometry while this provides valuable
information on what cell subsets are
present particularly immune suppressed
originally defined by multiple markers
as well as their level of regulatory
molecules such as PD 1 or PDL 1 what
have been missing is contact in other
words where each of those subsets is
located relative to each other and to
the tumor information obviously lacking
once the tissue architecture has been
disrupted
the Ultraflex technology was developed
to meet this unmet need for technology
which use robust quantitative and
multiplexed capable detecting multiple
biomarkers in a single tissue section
and which is fully compatible with
current pathology lab workflows
here are the goals we had in mind when
we developed the technology we wanted a
technology that was sensitive and
specific that was fast and simple
basically what we were aiming for was a
technology which followed a simple
standard pathway protocol of two steps
in two hours we also wanted one that was
practical and robust count approaches to
multiplex include limited to two three
marker staining by selecting programs
bodies of different species or isotypes
followed by staining using anti species
specific secondaries this is very
limited particularly as most antibodies
that are used are aiive mouse or rabbit
increasingly rabbit and that only has
one isotype our alternative approaches
to multiplexing using use repeated
rounds of stripping and staining which
is both lengthy and also requires very
careful planning of the order in which
the mark of esteem for each panel so
what we wanted was a much more practical
and robust approach we wanted one that
was reproducible and quantitative
someone that was scalable and easily
adaptable again we were aiming for a
kind of plug and play technology which
could be widely used we also wanted one
that conserve tissue given that we have
now progressed beyond simply looking at
diagnostic biopsies too frequently
looking at multiple in treatment
biopsies which are usually very tiny and
also precious those tiny biopsies are
divided up into analysis by multiple
different technologies so obviously we
wanted to get as much information as we
could from a single small tissue section
maybe one or two
but we also wanted a technology which
broadly applicable to analysis of all
tissues
so we frequently describe our
technologies flow cytometry inside you
and so people often ask why we can't
just use the same directly label
programs bodies that we use in slow
cytometry well occasionally you can but
as you can see here what we have is out
staining of a breast tumor biopsy with
antibodies against her - in red the
estrogen receptor in blue and the
progesterone receptor in green as you
can see the intensity of staining is
really pretty poor on the Sun directly
labeled specimen on the left however in
the on the right you can see the
amplification of fluorescence intensity
you get when you use a secondary
antibody amplification so here we have
it directly so we have an unlabeled
primary detected using anti species
specific secondaries and you can see the
very nice crisp membrane staining for
her tube in red
however this is limited obviously as I
mentioned before because there are not
very many different species of
antibodies and so this really isn't
amenable to multiplexing so here is what
you get when you use our Ultraflex
technology you can see very beautiful
crisp membrane staining in red for her -
and nuclear staining in blue ER and
green PR so we get about four to five
times the signal you get with directly
labeled primary antibodies and we get
between 70 to about 120 percent of what
we would see if we use the fluorescent
labeled anti species and body so it
combines the ability to multiplex but
also amplify as well
so how does Ultraflex work and Ultraflex
we add an individual different peptide
barcode as a hapten light tag to each
primary antibody so each primary it gets
a different peptide tag this means that
we can add all the different primary
antibodies together as a cocktail in one
step on the tissue section and incubate
just for one hour then we wash and we
come back with individual anti peptide
or peptide or anti 1/2 through
secondaries each of which is labeled
with a different floor
but simple cocktail of primary incubate
wash cocktail of secondary incubate wash
and then you're done a very simple
technology we routinely make standard
four-plex panels but we're continually
expanding our library of pet type tags
so we can also make five or six flex
panels beauty of Ultraflex is that it
doesn't matter whether we're looking at
three four or five markers
it still takes the same two steps and
two hours
so here is an example again of staining
a luminal B breast cancer biopsy for her
- you can see the nice membrane staining
in red the estrogen receptor that's the
nuclear staining in blue and the
progesterone receptor the nuclear
staining in green the fourth marker is a
proliferation marker ki-67 which is
actually pink but when get so it gets
overlaid with the other nuclear markers
here it appears as that kind of orange
color
so this highlight some key advantage of
our technology so the technology is
primary antibody species independent of
these four markers her two ER and PR or
or rabbit monoclonal PA 67 is a mouse
monoclonal so we our primary antibody
species independent agnostic it doesn't
matter to us we can also detect multiple
markers which Co Express in the same
cell compartment so for example ER PR
and K 67 or all nuclear markers we can
detect those very easily simultaneously
you can see here we get very good batch
to batch reproducibility we also have
our reproducibility and so here we have
serial slides stained with the same
panel on the same day so you get really
good slight slight reproducibility we
also get good batch to batch
reproducibility and also day to day
staining and we currently have over six
month stability on a number of our
panels
so serial section overlay of two three
or four sections gene with different
four types panels generates vast amounts
of data so the panels that are modular
we can stay in the different sections
with a different panel we can do image
registration overlay of both sections
and we call this super flexing so up on
up on the top left but again is staining
a breast cancer tumor with the breast
cancer panels down there on the bottom
right is a basic immune panel looking at
320 cell to should be cells or CD 3 cd4
cd8 t-cells
she almost before I overlay these two
you can really tell what's going on
that the immune cells in this particular
tumor are not gaining access to the
tumor tissue they are really very
restricted here to be to the stroma
so as must be immediately apparent one
of the main applications with this
technology is currently in the area of
in you know ecology where it allows
characterization of tumor infiltrating
immune valves the phenotype numbers the
levels of expression at checkpoint
market such as PD 1 and PDL 1 and
localization of me and cells relative to
the tumor and to each other this
potentially provides predictive markers
of response in immunotherapy
see the
identify multiple co expresses allows
detection of race or populations of
cells though here you can see detection
of this is a basic communal staining
console here you can see Co expression
of C D 3 and cd4 on T helper cells and C
D 3 and cd8 on cytotoxic T cells we can
potentially look at multiple multiple
markers on each subset so we can
identify very rare subpopulations of
cells so down here at the bottom you can
see Co expression of cd4 and T bet which
identifies th one helper cell DD form
Fox p3 is the middle of the small panels
at the bottom those would be tier egg
cells then we have cd8 and T better
expression and then the panel over to
the right is Co expression of cd4 t
bettan Sox B 3 which is a recipe which
is actually a kind of super suppressor
cell so we spend multiple different
tumor types
this slide shows staining of a head and
neck squamous cell carcinoma with a
panel looking at on the upper left PD on
one expression on different macrophage
subsets is shown by Co expression with
either cd68 and CD 163 that's the pink
standing of the orange staining which
you can see in this sample is pretty
much restricted to the macrophages are
pretty much restricted to the tumor as
opposed to PDL one expression the tumor
cells
so here the tumor cells are shown by the
purple and PDL one is the kind of um
aqua staining so in this particular
patient
most of the PDL one expression is on the
tumor and most of the macrophages are
restricted to the stroma the bottom left
panel is a t-cell subset panel so you
can see here very nicely I'm not sure
how it magnifies on your screen but the
Fox p3 staining is the red nucleus
around a green membrane staining so all
those little red dots surrounded by
green those are all tier egg cells the
yellow staining is looking at cd8
positive cytotoxic T cells so when you
do image registration
pursue affection overlay you can see
that you do get some infiltration of
tier X within the tumor but most of the
immune cells on the APCs are within the
stroma so I've only shown you two
overlays here and obviously we can
overlay three or four but it it becomes
very confusing to the eye really
visually we can just look at two but
it's obviously very amenable to large
data processing
this is another example showing staining
of lung cancer cells with our PDL one
panel Fauci I don't have a mouse I can't
show this to you but the tumor again is
in rather than if you look in the
central area section you can see kind of
a golden orange staining that is an
overlay showing PDL one expression
basically on the tumor in this in this
sample there is for a little PDL 1 on
the macrophages but those are shown very
nicely by beads kind of the purple
center surrounded by the green staining
those will be the cd68 D 153 double
positive macrophages and then if you
just kind of scan around the section you
can see some cells which are just purple
those are just a CD 68 single positive
macrophages this is another lung cancer
tissue section you can see it's a highly
infiltrated a tumor the cd20 positive B
cells are shown in purple there are very
few green cd8 positive cells but they
definitely are some and most of the T
cells are the cd4 positive T helper
cells but here is a very intense
infiltrations particular to the sample
the sustaining the thyroid gland the
pillory carcinoma can very strong
staining for PDL 1 that's the purple
restricted mainly to the to mushroom by
pan CK but as you look around there is a
little bit of purple showing on the DD
68 GD 163 positive macrophages as well
here this is our an immunity sore subset
panel looking I'm standing of thyroid
gland ciliary carcinoma and again you
can see they're very nice Fox p3
staining those red nuclei surrounded by
green membranes things so those are T
regs cytotoxic T cells are in kind of
aqua and P dl1 staining is in a kind of
pink caliber so these are our qualified
off-the-shelf multi-plex panels however
a lot of what we do is custom or
semi-custom panel developments of two to
six markers sometimes people want
entirely new panels or often they might
want to switch one marker in a panel for
another you know they maybe they want
such at PDL one for a different
checkpoint marker so we have additional
markers available from which RT bet
luxury and grams line b4 also
continually qualifying new antibodies
and have multiple targets and
developments
automated our quantitative scoring or
aqs was developed using Appirio cellular
email for a search algorithm so
clinically her two levels on a tumor are
designated as one plus two plus or three
plus and on the basis that they decide
whether to treat the patient with
Herceptin on Lap so here we show use of
the algorithm just setting arbitrary cut
points for her too and as you can see
down here on the bottom other two panels
the blue cells other oneplus cells the
green of the two plus cells and the pink
of the three plus cells however we're
currently involved in the study where
we're comparing her to staining using an
ultra ultra flex panel with pathology
scoring for her too so that in future we
can set clinically relevant cut points
but I heard you over the main reason I
mention this is because you can also
apply this to looking at level of
expression for any marker so here I'm
showing PDL one expression and as we all
know at this point while simply looking
for numbers of PDL one expressing cells
infiltrating a tumor doesn't give a
reliable predictor of a response to PDL
one checkpoint checkpoint blockade maybe
also looking at levels of expression of
PDL 1 comma with perhaps the presence of
over spell pipes within the tumor might
develop might allow development of a
predictive algorithm so who might
respond to PDL one checkpoint checkpoint
inhibition or to other checkpoint
inhibitors
so I'm sure that marie-louise will
discuss this in more detail but here we
show combining Ultraflex analysis using
staining with two three four or five
Plex panels with use of the appear genie
pattern recognition software to identify
tumor versus stromal regions one of the
lower panels where you can see identify
our identification of the stroma in a
kind of green color versus the tumour
and pink and then also combining that
with the appear cellular immune
oppresses algorithm which enables you to
identify eight different subsets based
on whether they Express what combination
of the RPO and her to the different cell
populations expressed and you can
combine all of those together to create
a virtual map
so by combining multiplex painting with
image registration of serial sections
overlaid we can look at four eight
twelve sixteen or even twenty plexus
paintings or if we use a six Plex panel
we can look at six twelve eight bytes
painting that means that we can identify
even very rare subpopulations themselves
expressing multiple markers we can look
at the percentage of resale as well as
the intensity of staining we can
calculate phenotype ratios and perform
proximity measurements of subsets of
cells relative not only to each other as
well as our presence within the stroma
versus the tumor region and distance to
the tool enlarges so this generates big
data obviously very amenable to machine
learning and artificial intelligence
so in summary Ultraflex allows
simultaneous detection of multiple
markers on a single tissue section
high-throughput simple and rapid
painting using cocktails of antibodies
and a single and retrieval step it is
primary antibody species independent and
compatible with Auto stain as images and
image analysis software
so through our CRS division path IDs we
provide both custom panel development a
lot of what we have are obviously immuno
oncology panels immune panels breast
cancer panels but we can generate any
custom panel that's required Rios
painting services imaging services and
also image analysis services
so we welcome everyone to visit the
website I'm sure you don't hesitate to
contact me at any time if you have any
questions and I think at this point I'll
just pass it over to Marie Louise
you
hello everybody thank you for joining us
today now I'm going to talk to you about
like a solution for fluorescence
multiplex imaging the products I'm going
to discuss are intended for research use
only they're not intended for diagnostic
purposes
they multiplex is most commonly
visualized with your essence using
technologies such as the elegant
Ultraflex adopt Snyder has just shown us
multiplex a phase benefit usually from
automation at every step
bane scam manage and analyze and these
are the four topics of my pastor
presentation our products are designed
to work on both bright red and
fluorescent slides 1 flex 2 flex or many
Plex assays special stains biomarkers
such as proteins and nucleic acids or
form assays that we can actually manage
on our stains and manage and analyze
systems so from staying through scan
manage and analyze our platforms are
designed to work together or complement
any manual steps the user prefers to
rely on
so here are some examples of different
staining protocols perform on the bond
directs the concentrate on the two lower
images their fluorescence and they're
clearly multiplex the lower left has six
colors especially a five plexus a with a
ducky can stain the lower right images a
four-plex after again using Daffy as a
counterstain these are typical of the
new oncology multiplex pathways that are
invoked today basically these sort of
assays are all about phenotyping
themselves the immune cells interaction
with a tumor can be distinguished by
specific biomarkers such as helper T
cells are stained with cd4 killer T
cells are stained with cd8 B cells are
marked up with CB 20 regulators T cells
are marked up with Fox p3 and the tumor
cells are usually denoted with something
like a cytokeratin what's critical about
this is rarely that the stains overlap
nests the cells are overlapping in a
very crowded tightly dense tissue
structure but it's usually about
identifying individual cells that have
one and maybe two stains associated with
them how do we get to these image let's
look at my first topic which is about
the auto statement
so there are currently two machines in
the RX range of automatic stainer and
neither intended for research the
freestanding RX there on the left and
then it's baby brother the benchtop RX m
basically both going to do the same job
for you
performing fully automated stain
protocol for up to 30 sides in three
trays the main difference is the size of
the reagent tanks on the dump tanks so
it is easy to use it's fast consistent
and will get your slides done with a
minimum fuss the three independent trays
means up to three different protocols
can be carried out simultaneously
if you have full flexibility there even
better bonds may have been
pre-programmed protocols to work
specifically with like of bio systems
reagents more importantly it's actually
open for other detection kits and
reagents so you don't have to abandon
your favorite systems in the lab just
because you're taking on automatic stain
up after the bond bond also supports
custom protocols what I mean by this is
the user can set the number the order
the time even the temperature of every
step you have full control here once the
staining is complete your slides maybe
one slides maybe certain slide or
however many you're running through your
system these n enter what I call the
Imperium
and this is the second part of my talk
it's the second topic after staining the
user could visualize the slides with
standard fluorescent microscope all I
can say is good luck to that I've done
that kind of thing for years and it's
whole multiplex images often utilized
rulers in the near infrared range which
are not visible to the human eye do you
need to actually digitize multiplex
slides to start with even if you're not
using side five or one of these other
and practically invisible markers that
you cannot see with a naked eye it's
still incredibly difficult to get it
straight in your mind all the different
games that you may be looking at to
their period versus scanner is a
research scallops designed to handle
multiplex lights with the load with ease
really take all the pain away just like
the bombs can it will generate perfectly
aligned tile-based fluorescent images in
the range from 350 nanometers up to 750
nanometers to you and me that's anything
from Daffy to size 7 included that's a
pretty broad spectrum you get to choose
between the 8 Bay or the 200 load of
fellow though that you cannot see that
is up to you when and how those Sirte
sliders will come off the bond versa
also has an 8 positioned dichroic turret
buried in the heart of the microscope it
handle all sorts of different sort of
you're from multiplex assay with ease
using a very standard fluorescent system
first I had a range of objectives to
choose from - there are some slides can
be scanned at any magnetic magnification
from 5x to 63 X so you're not relying on
a magnified 20x image but true
resolution at 40 and 63 X using 1463 X
objectives do you want even more where
you can actually apply an automatic
oiler to the system and use oil
immersion lens of 640 and 63 and then
lead can really enable you to use
understand er for fish scanning very
easily it's great for tissue fish
so this is what you get beautiful images
from a highly separable scanner with a
simple user interface so they're set up
and scanning it's got all 200 slides
there all you have to do is set your
scan template in the top right click on
a file destination in the bottom left
and then highlight the slides so that's
again template if you want to have
different destinations and scan
templates ignore 200 batteries in your 8
batch if you're using the APA you can
you can mix bright will turn
fluorescents in the same batch good
system doesn't care it will just take a
slide knows what it's got to do in it
and do it for you perfectly want to see
what's happening at every every part at
the end of every path where you can do
you can review and export the scans
manually or you can just believe it let
it get on with this job and scan the
whole lot for you you can monitor it
usually at a glance you can see that 7'o
both slides are ready for review one of
them is in red that's telling me that
needs a little it's not she been happy
with what it's tried to scan you have
the chance to go back review it tell it
to scan it again where you can dump it
and continue with the other 7 as you
like calibration can be is automatically
flexible and in-depth as you want
for fluorescence you can set automatic
exposure for every floor instead you can
actually set variety of different
settings for each floor you can have
some on automatic some on manual
exposure that you calibrate itself on
your slides you can also set beds back
and they can be different for every
floor if you've got full control here so
advisor you can now capture as much
detail for as many cells as you want on
your multiplex lines
why does magnification matter than
looking at fluorescence images well the
obvious answer is that it does so let's
go through a little bit of why on what
we do to overcome some of the
limitations low resolution is great you
get a lot of fat cells in one single
tile but we should really call
field-of-view we've got good focus but
unfortunately the detail is not great do
small spots that together are going to
be very hard to see clearly at low
magnification but you've got good focus
to get more details metering freeze
resolution use a higher magnification
objective but you get a shorter focal
depth you're also really annoying get
fewer cells in your field of view so we
end up time to take more tiles back to
more field of view to get the same
number of cells at Lowton
the focus becomes more critical of
higher education objectives
and it's very important that you handle
it properly here at lighter Biosystems
we actually solve this with a
time-honored fashion within our company
and that's using Zed stacking so what we
do is that we take their stacks going
above through and below the perceived
focal points focal plane for each floor
to ensure your tissue is always
perfectly captured managing these web
stacks the system then figures out what
signal is actually in focus
what is Haysom unfocused using something
called nearest neighbor deconvolution
methodology not a physicist or a
mathematician but all I can say is in my
opinion it works brilliantly
look at those two images and the bottom
line we generate a maximum intensity
projection which is a summation of all
those signals that are in focus on
different setbacks that you've got in
our case we actually keep the maximum
tensile perception and also the input
subsets you can always go back to those
walk data and staff through but the
level of detail you now get because of
this key convolution is outstanding and
you can now interpret your multiplexed
slides with ease and a great deal of
confidence
the bustle generates whole slide images
at any magnification
do you like we say is scout and 5 X 4 6
through yet and you can do a whole slide
at any of those magnifications in
between 5 X 10 20 40 or 63 a little bit
crazy to consider those multiplex from
63 with red stacks 4 separate colors on
the whole slide that's going to be
several tens if not hundreds of
gigabytes in size but hey the capability
is there the reality is on 63 X you're
probably going to be focusing in very
specific areas of the slide but you
still got the capability of getting a
large beautiful image at any
magnification issue an expert then yes
you can focus in on the area of the
slider interesting you can spend time on
a scanner making sure you're only
capturing those areas but if you need
the help of a friendly local pathologist
it's much easier to actually review that
the image once it's been scanned in a
sitting on a PC or you know view it on
the monitor than it is to crowd around
the scanner anthropologist and I
actually about the scan the right bit
I spent a lot of time with Manuel for us
at microscopes capturing single fields
of view and it was heartbreaking because
time and time again it was afterwards
when the fluorescence was long dead
I realize that I haven't quite got the
right bit I'm a big fan of this
capability to whole slide image the
reality is most the time you would be
using 20 or maybe 40 X 4 whole slide
imaging and the 40 X is a true 40 X
resolution because it's using a 40 X
objective versus generates whole sine
images from individual tiles or fields
of view that are captured sequentially
as you go across the slide so it works
across the short axis of the slide going
lose thousands position takes the canvas
saying then takes the SERS or the
exposures or the bed stacks moving a
dichroic it's time to slide itself never
miss once the tile is fully captured
then with the scanner then moves to
slide on to the next half and does the
same thing and it takes the whole run
for tiles it goes back to one side of
slide again and does the next run of
tile and then from that you get this
incredibly beautiful seamless image that
you can see here on the right the lines
that are showing there are actually
lines I drew on to show where the actual
tiles are incorporated they're
overlapping and then merge together so
you get this beautiful seamless tissue
to look at you always get perfect
context and all your tissue sections for
generating all these multiplexers is
easy right so it would appear so but I
can promise you managing them can be in
an even bigger headache
I mentioned that you can get hundreds of
gigabytes and then it's why I actually
have seen certain gigabyte images being
circulated it was really fun and games
trying to get those around the business
to different sites its pretty long
external drive you can send it through
the post but what happens if that gets
lost it's incredibly easy to lose these
images and or even delete them by
accident if you're not actually using a
proper image management system
shirring as I said you can post an
external drive we certainly can't email
something that's bigger than about 20 of
certain next three days file sharing
platforms high experience atop tails
about 500 dick per single file so even
though I might have a terabyte of space
on one of my arms showing backbones
I'm actually only limited to 5 gigabytes
size files
so instead if you were to use something
like Irish management software called
the period image slide manager so again
clear this slide manager it will manage
to share your images faster and serve
with more secure securely and this is my
third topic clear the manage part of the
talk the east laganja is really easy to
use whatever files are sitting on a
single central server and you use a
web-based application to log in and work
and access and view the slides every
login has its own permissions so some
people might be able to do slides other
people might be prevented from doing
certain slides we certain can stop
people from generating slides with its
robust built-in security available
research designs protected from prying
eyes and also importantly delete buttons
while you're single out with everyone
there everyday well what obsession may
be the option for you basically you will
scale the slides to and point them at a
single PC everyone would then work
walked about PC and access the image
management on that PC and also access a
range of image analysis tools to help
you interpret your multiplex images
that's a pretty good neat solution on a
small scale you can scale it up instead
you can actually go to a server based
solution if you're a large lab or a poor
facility you have important
collaborators another building block on
campus or even off-campus these cloud
manager is its server solutions as its
most powerful and flexible you can hook
up all your scanners religious images
direct to the server each image is ready
within seconds of the scan being
completed
it's not about waiting to a whole batch
to complete every single image is
treated others as individual files gets
uploaded you have control over each one
each login on what it can do so local
users can just access it from a PC
within the lab remote users can use
something like a VPN to get secure
access so you can work not just from
home but also from the other side of the
world if you've got a satellite sites
that might need its own image management
it's got its own scanner and local
storage server you can do that and those
local users can look at their images and
they can also look at the main site
images if necessary so it's easier to
share between the two sites all about
Commission's
orcid interested we do never surprise
superior also does image analysis this
is the fourth and final topic in my talk
believe it or not this is the reason why
we actually digital digitize multiplex
lives our baby thinking huh right now
people don't do more suplex assays to
scan slides but they actually do
multiplex to interpret complex biology
of really difficult questions is what
immune cells are infiltrating that tumor
how is that going to affect whether that
tune is going to progress or whether we
can kill it off with drugs that's the
kind of questions people are asking
they're difficult questions to answer
and that's why multiplex is being
developed image analysis can actually
help you without interpretation and more
importantly although you can get a lot
of data by looking at the images
digitally yourself it's actually
algorithms are able to mine more data
out of art we call this data mining in
ways that you can't possibly do man a
bit if that's extraordinary days you can
get off this stuff our appear algorithms
have been out about now for about 15
years and we used by more than 300
organizations in 40 plus countries more
than 300 peer-reviewed publications
sightings the algorithms must be doing
something like so let me show you a bit
more
this is the research use image analysis
menu 14 algorithms divided into machine
learning applications analysis proteins
and immunofluorescence mr chemistry
methods and molecular analysis which is
actually nucleic acid probe such as RNA
and DNA the numbers on each algorithm
actually indicate the numbers of colors
the algorithm will support you on the
left there for Julian TM a lab is
actually for unlimited it's hardly
surprising with tools for segmenting and
managing TM a doesn't care about plex
actually neither does Jeannie and
juniors are powerful pattern recognition
software and that can identify your
regions of interest they were Jeannie
you can make your own robust ship
classifiers that look for your tissue
your particular stains and direct
analysis for the correct areas of your
slides
you can come very expert without having
to refer to a pathologist each time you
can help cover pathologists helps you
build a classifier and then you're
actually freeing up their time there is
no more annotations no more mistakes
especially in highly heterogeneous
slides after the machine learning tools
tuning team a lab barely arena for
essence is the winner in the Flex takes
is the top left in the protein section
it supports nine colors specifically it
supports seven targets and to Kansas
things I'll tell you a bit about my bit
more about this uh planning algorithm in
a minute it's a perfect example of the
revitalization of their pure image
analysis program design Tsering customer
needs for multiplex now and really does
legend that that image analysis from a
period is open for business what a
walk-on how is a bright yellow ribbons
or two or three color so this actually
means that it's one two Plex targets we
really care about well actually most
bright field imaging is still one and
two Plex so we are able to support the
vast majority of room
immunohistochemistry and chroma Jenica
fish off a filter out or at the moment
watch this space there will be more to
come
here it is let's go through your period
cellular Nina fluorescent sparkle
whatever mouthful but it's worthless
we designed it to mimic how you'd work
down a microscope what I mean by that if
you look on the right there you can see
the different paths how we bought the
parameters to basically can go through
what I looking at would I say that to
sell without say that positive staining
how let's call that sells it type exit
I'd why where are my final totals if you
take that image on the top floor height
you can end up with a markup that's
within my bow on the top bottom side
the mobile the fold accurately we've
industry-leading
double stamp counter same cell modeling
there's the standard nuclear counter
same you can use the DEF feed or you
could even use that red stain as only
marking up some utilize you can use any
stain you want for your nuclear marker
then got a choice of either painting on
the cytoplasm and the membrane to set
depth or you can actually use another
count to save or another die in this
case the green stain in that's like to
model the cytoplasm for the membrane
just as accurately as you are the
nucleus so you're modeling beyond the
nuclear boundary with confidence why
does this matter you just paint on side
has another set depth around Lucas not
really giving the real shape of the Sun
you could get Starbucks and more results
and really get confused you can see here
that I've actually used the green fluid
to model the size problem so the cells
are more cell shape and the size hasn't
only exists where there's green state
like your mouth pretty neat multiplex
painting patterns can be complex I show
you here to target for red and green on
adaptive campus day but how do you keep
seven targets straight in your head
they'll all have different portents of
threshold between what's positive and
negative staining there might be in one
or more different cell compartments it's
not too bad to do seven things on this
two dozen cells that are in this image
here what if you've got to do a whole
slide that could be half a million cells
or more you keep that straight in your
heads of seven things over half a
million cells good luck because you're a
better person than me there's no way I
could try and then you've got to
remember you're not just got the five
hundred thousand souls on this slide
what about all the different cells on
the other slides that come off your
batch of thirty from the bond rx famer
it's not easy to characterize a cell
population with automatic classification
from this algorithm if you're doing or
intending to do multiplex assays it
makes sense to use Appirio image of the
artists to generate those numbers for
you
lots of settled here in there to go will
result ecology every sound does count
you've gone through all that trouble of
staining and imaging all those cells you
should consider them all in interpreting
your multiplex at site just look at
these three cells here a B and C each of
the different size color and shape
totals and averages really I'm not going
to get tell you the whole story a cell
data could actually give you a much
bigger picture it's complex but it could
be critical to the quality of your final
results don't disregard it that's all
for topic for colored stains can manage
and Ally this let go through how it all
hangs together in a workflow in via
period
now website come out the website wet lab
are in the imperial system you've got in
USA you make a new vs cam template in
seconds literally just take seconds you
can cheat and copy an existing one you
then set your exposures you dead stacks
with the floors and ghosts and you've
got the confidence to know that that
slide is finished that image will
automatically upload to your slide
management system you can see it as soon
as it's available you can have a look at
it on the viewer and do what you want
with it if you want to actually use
engine artists to help you interpret the
image you actually need to tune an
outrigger in this case is fairly
immunofluorescence algorithm to get some
multiplex I say roll it up in the viewer
and we call this tuning algorithm get
the ticket you set it up to Detective
targets and count the stains detect the
scoring classes and then you save it as
something we call a macro that's just a
file it's just a version of the
algorithm specific to that particular
asset you then annotate the slides so if
you say these are the areas of slide I
want to analyze
you know Intel system to run the
analysis and just sit back and wait for
results you can watch it go at like or
you can work the way and do it when it's
ready
the point about saving our macro is you
can actually go in and edit it time and
time again you can tweak it until you're
happy that's right so you're not just
setting up this painting and scanning
got you get the analysis interpretation
just how you want it but for control
then once you're happy with it
we actually don't have to tune anymore
you scan your slides the upload to image
management you then bipod tuning you
just annotate the slide
tell it to batch analyze and that's
literally where you select your slides
select your macro cally slide manager go
analyze these layers and it will do that
it will spit out results that you can
view where and when you're ready to view
you have can have complete confidence
within your the jaw multiplex si will
actually continue and complete in their
period one so let's look at the cell
Universal algorithm action I'm just
going to take a really simple three
color image we've got tons and tons of
useful multicolored and just but showing
you how the algorithm works it's
actually more powerful just showing you
with just a cup of targets here red
staining is actually so factually
spectrum orange but we've got pseudo
colored it red for good contrast it's
the estrogen receptor greenness slider
keratin Luis Debbie chemists a pretty
standard stuff
I can model this to determine what cells
have what stains if I just go back a bit
you can see that we've got green in the
site the cytoplasm we've got red and
some nuclei we don't have all cells with
red we don't have all cells with green
so I want to quantitate what cells are
red what a green one of those was man
would have maybe a few z combinations in
between ratio staining these are results
so you'll get overall but I'll go
through the first aisle in a minute from
this area here I've got two thousand two
hundred and seven cells counted I can
see a lot of data from the overall
results and see the name of dye wanna
see all the names died she was slighted
Kara tonight I can see how many cells
have ER in that cytoplasm and how many
felt of keratin in the cytoplasm to many
psychos what if I didn't know where the
biomarker wasn't myself what if it was
in several different compartments of the
cell that doesn't matter through this
algorithm I can actually set any of my
tests seven tests died to fit in the
nucleus the cytoplasm some membrane and
choose the single compartment
I can choose multiple compartments for
each one of those Deseret eclis i could
be actually looking at 21 different
combinations or locations of my markers
that's seven times three compartments
extraordinary level of detail we can get
rid of sample do you want to know how
much you vineeth this how they are
staying on average while it's there too
and it's that you're telling me
22% visio amy is not all over the
nucleus in every cell it's very patchy
and you can actually start to see and
infer different things
the numbers are also of the school and
classes are present there are
color-coded beads to make it easier to
see so you can see a class 1 class 2
class 3 class 4 and class 5 you can see
the range of the numbers of cells I've
got in each of those classes color coded
is to match the marker that you get on
the mask just to make it easier you can
see that most cells actually fall into
class 5 which is actually dr- ck8
negative that's because I've set
thresholds who I was considered positive
staining quite high for both the size I
set that as lower I would have had fewer
cells in my negative classes myself in
those combinations of positive classes
there note that I use cytokeratin to
model the cytoplasm accurately but I
also analyzed it so using something as a
counter segment is not excluded from
analysis I think that's really useful
what about if I wanted to to snow how
strong is the intensity of the ER any
cells this is like ants astounded
immunohistochemistry I say that people
might would do in a breast panel so you
want to know one plus two plus three
plus standing for ER and tumor cells
when I can identify the tumor cell
because they would be green they would
have that ck8 staining i can then set
four classes as well it's negative [ __ ]
fill out another one that's low one plus
medium two plus strong three plus four
er positive nuclei I can then save the
macro run the analysis result is got
still got two hundred two thousand two
hundred and seven cells and the result
is it's two plus line because actually
you've got you don't have enough cells
in the three plus class the high
intensive class to actually constitute
three parts you have to have at least
10% of cells where you actually reach
the 10% when you're in these two plus
class so we actually can say this is a
to bust result do you want it all
well you can have combinations of
biomarkers and their intensities and the
area which they occupy the compartment
view are saying all seven flex we've got
huge amount of data you can generate
from this right there on your PC and all
you have to do is set up on micrograms
so this is castle output it's actually a
very very long table here it's a grid
underneath the overall results the
overall results you're only seeing the
dates start and end time so you can see
the audit trail there but here in the
results you can I'm actually displaying
six cells here each row represents a
cell and you can see that you've got
data like the presence or absence in a
class the area of nucleus the area of
data counter State and you can actually
find out and put a lot of data for each
cell from this and if I with the page
down you would see that I would actually
be able to review for 2207 cells I can
get the air in shape of each cell act
and get data on intensity concentration
areas same for every school and every
cell and there's so much more because
people want to do stats on themselves we
can do a one click export' do to make a
CSV file that can go into any third
party spreadsheet application and I
often do do that you can start to
soldier and comes down and office you
can filter here you can see that I've
got a filter on the presence in the
orange class both present present in
class orange tree class you can see that
I'm showing the ones there they're the
ones with a presence in the class
what you're doing start from these cells
I've got 2,000 salty what if I do start
from 512 themselves that's pretty
significant but what if you've got to do
school half a million cells on each of
those 30 stains like that came off the
bundle the beginning of the talk that's
15 million cells after a lot of stats
you need a player
don't just have to rely on stats you can
review yourselves individually as you
can see here I'm able to filter on that
chat presence in a class orange 3 plus
and I actually highlighted that
so-called 1323 you can see here it's
indicated on the mark up with a red box
around and I know at a glance it's a 3
plus because I consider the one in the 3
plus column in the grid and also its
dark red and I set up this path day a
little bit presently but my blue is
going to be negative staining my yellow
was going to be one plus my can was
going to be 2 plus and my dark red was
going to be a 3 plus software or just
helps you foot sort through so I can
click on each of the cells in that grid
almost resolve the time among all
highlight in the markup that's great
looking at the markup but actually I can
hide the mask and look at the cell
itself underneath and I can see that
that's an intense through strange it
ourselves and I can actually look at the
other cells surrounding and if I were to
go backwards and forwards on this slide
a few times you can see white some of
the cells are blue that negative we've
got one one plus cell and the rest are
two plus ok so that's actually how you
deep dive into every cell for one round
with a final thought ask yourself what
would you own to count personalized
manually back in the day I'd be doing
100 500 cells foul rules if I really was
pushed how to do for Correia million not
happily not on one slide not without
losing my marbles and I've got so she
left what about those other flies near
bonds acts that I'm expecting there
could be 15 million cells at the least
almost like you look at it's all adding
up and crucially is backing up rapidly
without the aid of automation tool to
handle that kind of data so on that
final note I'm going to thank you for
your attention today and for if there
any questions thank you
thank you dr. Schneider and dr. Rupert
for your informative presentations we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer a question box located on
the far left of your screen we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
let's get started
dr. Schneider this quick question is for
you how many markers can you detect
simultaneously
a question we routinely detect while
Marcos simultaneously using four
different peptide hats and month I have
tempers but we are continuously
expanding our library of peptides and to
detect four five or six markers at the
same time if needed essentially the only
limitation will ultimately be the number
of fluorophores you're able to detect
them all taneous ly and that you need to
distinguish one from the other
thank you doctor the part let's have you
answer this one do you need different
kinds of scanners for fish and
immunofluorescence
actually the answer is yes alone the two
techniques do benefit from different
resolution and stamping methods fish
really does like the 63 and the 40 X
does like to use a little reinforces you
can often get away with I've seen 10x
out 13 20 X a lot 40 X is becoming quite
popular from you know for essence we're
actually announces and 63 X Riverina
threatened if you've got a standard line
base card that you're using from you
know for essence and you want to do fish
the answer then is yes you do it in a
different kind of scanner life scanners
use use use of 20 X or using all users
mm lens to generate a 40 X image and
these won't have sufficient resolution
to resolve or separate those two closely
located fish spot signals especially if
you're doing a break apart fusion
nothing will happen for half of the line
stammers not all but the one I'm
thinking of the ticular but you know we
do have no portfolio is that it captures
each floor enough strips and
side-to-side on the slide and then it
aligns it strips afters well there's a
real alignment issue there so how could
you be sure that you've got the
confidence your great fusion as those
are as clean as it could be
fish really does benefit if you've got a
tile based scanner but all the floor web
stacks are captured in one before the
slide moves on to the next time so it's
much more likely you'll end up a tomato
[ __ ] are aligning but you can look at
the individual cells in each of those
piles and know that properly aligned
label the signals are aligned usually
got versa the answer is no you do need
different kinds of scan you've got a
two-for-one as best of both words
sitting on your bench but a wide range
of objectives all the oil and dead stuff
even-even got this fabulous little fish
enhancement session I never went into
that it really does clean up your fish
images because we've actually helping
you use the Daffy mask to make sure
you're getting the right fish signals
within the nuclei compared to potential
artifacts painting outside anika really
neat little system if' and fish can lead
to come together on the same instrument
and the really brilliant thing is was
that before you can actually
design batch using different spam
templates so reverse' use W to different
kind of scanner form our scanners can be
limited in the uses I came for a fish or
essence from a cup thank you
okay dr. Schneider back to you are you
able to detect Mouse antibodies on Mouse
tissue using full triplets
yes one advantage of
flex technology is that it separately
barcodes each programs body with a
different happen the detects using anti
hapten antibodies instead of anti
species-specific secondaries
so it makes no difference does either
the species of the tissue or the species
of the primary antibody this means that
the technology has very wide
applicability in a whole variety of
models
dr. Schneider let's piggyback on that
last question can you tell us on what
other tissues have Ultraflex than you
so Autoplex can be used on both FFPE
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tissues
and also frozen tissue sections and we
have stained a wide variety of tumor
types using all perplexed panels are off
the top of my head these range from
multiple subtypes of breast cancer had
an X crema cell carcinoma prostate
cancer lung cancer squamous cell
carcinoma of the cervix gall bladder
i'm nô carcinoma thyroid gland Tillery
carcinoma i think we just looked at some
of those images I'm just a few minutes
ago melanoma and pancreatic cancer we've
also stained real issue with
glomerulonephritis and of course we
always routinely stain normal human
tissue such as tonsil and development of
all of these panels but there's
obviously no reason why this technology
could not be applied to many different
tissues and disease states
you
and we have indeed saying other tissues
also
just coming in for da fiel apart
Stockdale apart how do you decide on
what floors to use for multiplex
or bond versa and cellular amina
fluorescence algorithm can all manage
many different combinations of flows you
can just continue to work with your
favorites that you already got in the
lab you don't have to spend time
validating the you stay in our new
detection methodology which can be
expensive and it can really drain
resources as we try to replace your
existing methods that were already
working a careful choice of narrowband
dichroic filters on the scanner will
actually reduce overlap of bleed through
flaws and if you look at that range that
I talked about earlier from Dappy at
three fifty two five seven and seven
fifty it's possible to have four six or
maybe even seven separate fluids through
30 and five seven are actually two of
them you could easily drop in the likes
of aqua spectrum green maybe a spectrum
gold some sort of spectrum red or Texas
red getting inside seven and also
dropping in Syfy's between the red and
the sky seven it is possible to get up
there need to do the test and we need to
check that it works that you're kind of
assay but I believe it's possible
software then will just actually take
all those the images that come off the
wrapper it each of the changes its own
grade scale and it will then just
interpret each scale and give you a
final full color result it's simple
flexible and it keeps you in control of
your essay at three times
required let's say on this topic for the
next question how easy is it to manually
gain multiplex
okay so manual sailing is pretty
laborious takes up a lot of a technician
valuable time
all those set all those washers even
technology such as cell IDs with
ultratex they will reduce many headaches
but is still looking a lot of steps
potentially there's all the variation
just need to get distracted by a phone
cord or something and your timing could
be off when you're doing this manually
the board orx automatic spanner is a
setup and Lookaway system that will save
time and provide consistency whatever
the same technology at you do you set
out to go and while Armageddon that
thing will finish your sailing for you
and it will be the same as the previous
that time again user still needs to
ensure the same is working correctly in
the first place you have to set it up
and check that it's as good as your
manual you've got to make sure your
antibodies are well characterized and
they're actually locating where they're
supposed to there is a lot out only
literature of the moment that you know
no two antibodies from different vendors
might might actually be hitting the
correct target because we've all been
generated in different ways got to be
right clear on what you you've actually
created especially if it's a home made
antibodies not important the antibodies
reception system are titrated correctly
she's got you're reducing the chance of
cross reaction or even blocking his
target these are just a couple of
examples what he was born Rx takes some
of the labor away
and while we're talking about staining
dr. Snyder can you share with us how
long the staining process takes
basically the standing process takes two
hours and the two steps all of our hats
and logic primaries and on perhaps and
secondary or a plate as cocktails that's
the really nice thing about this
technology so regardless of whether we
perform a standing four three four or
five markers the process is the same
it's a one-hour standing with the
primary cocktail wash and then a
one-hour standing with a secondary
cocktail there's only one function
retrieval step prior to this so it saves
that a great deal of time compared to
other tips techniques which we use
multiple different answering retrieval
steps
dr. Schneider one more question for you
now we see what other technologies use
multiple antigen retrieval steps but you
aren't only uses one why is this
well firstly we screen around bodies and
ffp tissue under different antigen
retrieval conditions and then
intentionally select condition which
worked well for the antibodies in the
panel it was very important to us that
this technology be as simple robust and
easily adaptable as possible second we
have only one antigen retrieval step
because we have simultaneous binding and
detection of all markers so unlike other
technologies there's no need for
multiple rounds or stripping and
staining or optimization of different
individual antibody pairs in terms of
the detection sequence the order in
which those antibody pairs are applied
to the tissue
thank you dr. Schneider we have time for
two more questions dr. Lockhart let's
have you answer these last two how does
the SW manage to segment cells
accurately
multiplex our roads up shall you Mina
fluorescence and actually also the two
fish algorithms that I didn't really
talk about have more than 15 parameters
used to identify segments counterstain
fluorescently appealing is it overkill
probably not they do used additional
parameters initially such as merging
smoothing slide filtering but then they
ever we've also incorporates things like
noise reduction a machine learning to
handle those crowded novolac of nuclei
more effectively it can be quite tricky
especially in fish where the cells are
subjected to a huge denaturation shock
to actually be the individual nuclei
they tend to look a little bit
differently doing immunofluorescence
Zaki staining so our algorithms are
designed to actually combat that kind of
issue the live with tuning window that
we have gives real-time feedback when
you're tuning to see how effective
segmentation is as you change the
parameter you can see within a second or
so what that change is to the light in
the light window then after analysis if
you really don't want some of the nuclei
like it's marked up some of the cell you
can actually edit them you can delete
them out you can do that at the point in
the grid the per cell grid and then
export the results or you can actually
do it in third party especially later if
you don't like it a lot of control there
at each step
and let's end with this great question
is automatic analysis really faster than
a person scoring
aha man or woman versus machine the old
question well to be perfectly honest for
one or two techs essays on a few slide
it's probably not going to be faster on
the machine but when it comes to
multiplex the limitations to man-up and
digital really starts to win out for
speed accuracy and reproducibility it's
all about how many markers can you keep
straight in your head what do they all
mean the cut-offs for each marker can
vary over vary and overlapping cells can
make manuals growing incredibly
difficult remain consistent the
algorithm will handle that and the
slides when they mount up in number use
does get tired too the software really
doesn't so you can get generate counts
of 50 100 200 cells quickly manually but
you're not going to get thousands unless
you're using software to help you
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions just to
reminder any questions we did not have
time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank loggers and our sponsor leica
Biosystems for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through October 2018
bobrucz will alert you via email when it
is available for replay we encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye